I've always loved the 911 for the money
and in a manual version it's probably
the most fun to drive car money can buy
but I don't like the fact that everyone
from my dentist to my broker seems to
have one it makes me wish for something
a bit more unique so I was very happy to
see the new 911 Targa 4 GTS consider it
Porsches attempt to reach a broader
swath of buyers and maybe even reach a
few women or younger people to this one
by the way cost more than one hundred
and forty seven thousand dollars
including options like Bose sound and
Sport Chrono badging it comes with a
fully automatic fabric top that recedes
in a matter of seconds the Targa glass
roof operates separately from that top
it's a really special 911 this is the
target it's based on the 1970s Targo
model and Porsche did a great job of
making the modern version seem nostalgic
to the older one
it's got a sweet engine it's the Porsche
911 6-cylinder aluminum engine 430
horsepower and it feels great it makes
it to 60 miles per hour in four seconds
you can choose PDK paddle shifting on
its 7-speed all wheel drive transmission
but opt for the manual version the hold
function makes is an easy manual to
drive even in ileus neighborhoods the
automatic start/stop function helps
achieve 18 miles per gallon in the city
and 26 on the highway it even received
the government's low emission vehicle
certification inside welcoming suede
covers everything and the central tech
ometer optional red instrument dials and
genius hidden cupholders enhance the
dual goals of this car to drive fast and
look cool while you do it so all things
considered is it worth it
well yeah between the way it feels to
drive the target and nostalgia and the
interior trim yeah it's definitely worth
it I say go for it